hoy vamos a hablar de los efectos
generales de una mutación genética y
cómo las mutaciones afectan al organismo
en su conjunto pero primero quiero
revisar el dogma central de la biología
molecular y cómo la información genética
de una célula se almacena en forma de
adn que luego se transcribe para formar
a rn que posteriormente se traduce para
formar una proteína los nucleótidos del
adn se transcriben a sus formas
complementarias en el adn que luego se
leen como cordones o grupos de tres para
codificar aminoácidos específicos en una
proteína más grande si alteramos uno de
los nucleótidos en el adn como cambiar
esta base de timina en una base adenina
eso afectará la secuencia a rn y en
última instancia la proteína que sigue
decimos que las mutaciones son
generalmente cambios en el adn de una
célula que conducen a la producción
anormal de proteínas entonces las
mutaciones son buenas o malas y qué tipo
de efecto tienen sobre el organismo
afectado bueno realmente no hay una
buena respuesta a esta pregunta hay
muchos tipos diferentes de mutaciones
que pueden dar lugar
grandes cambios estructurales como las
imágenes que he dibujado aquí o pueden
dar lugar a pequeños y sutiles cambios
que pueden pasar completamente
desapercibidos sin embargo es muy
difícil llamar a una mutación buena o
mala ya que realmente depende de una
gran cantidad de cosas incluido el
entorno en el que vive el organismo
veamos un ejemplo de una buena mutación
la bacteria streptococcus pneumoniae es
la bacteria que normalmente se asocia
con la neumonía uno de los tratamientos
más populares para la neumonía es darle
a la persona infectada un antibiótico
como la penicilina lo que ayudaría a
eliminar todas las bacterias y eliminar
la enfermedad pero a veces se pueden
encontrar algunas bacterias
streptococcus mutans que tendrán un
rasgo especial que las hace resistentes
a la penicilina y ahora la penicilina no
las matará tan fácilmente como matará a
las bacterias sin la mutación llamamos a
esto una buena mutación porque las
bacterias viven en un hospedero humano
donde probablemente se encuentren con
esta penicilina mortal para ellas al ser
resistentes a los antibióticos como la
penicilina sería beneficioso
las bacterias sólo para aclarar lo llamó
una buena mutación para las bacterias no
realmente para los humanos infectados ya
que será más difícil deshacerse de las
bacterias que son resistentes a ciertos
antibióticos veamos un ejemplo de una
mala mutación la enfermedad fibrosis
quística generalmente es causada por una
mutación en el gen cftr no voy a entrar
en detalles sobre cómo esta mutación
realmente afecta al individuo pero les
diré que lo que hace es espesar la
mucosidad que se encuentra en los
pulmones de una persona lo que dificulta
mucho la respiración de las personas
afectadas con la enfermedad en general
podemos decir que una mutación que causa
fibrosis quística sería una mutación
mala entre comillas pero las mutaciones
no son estrictamente buenas o
estrictamente malas de hecho hay algunas
mutaciones que pueden causar algunos
efectos favorables y algunos
desventajosos la enfermedad de células
falciformes es el resultado de una
mutación en una proteína llamada
hemoglobina que se encuentra en los
glóbulos rojos esta mutación convierte
la hemoglobina hb en
la forma mucho menos funcional que
llamaremos hs es mucho menos eficiente
para mover el oxígeno por el cuerpo
humano otro efecto de la enfermedad de
células falciformes es que hace que la
persona enferma sea menos susceptible a
la malaria la malaria es un parásito que
crece y se multiplica en los glóbulos
rojos y puede tener muchos efectos
desagradables en el organismo hospedero
el parásito de la malaria no puede
crecer bien en los glóbulos rojos
afectados por la enfermedad de células
falciformes en este caso la mutación
asociada con esta enfermedad tiene un
efecto negativo que es que el hbs no es
tan bueno para transportar oxígeno por
el cuerpo pero también tiene un buen
efecto ya que hace que sea menos
probable que la persona enferma sea
afectada por la malaria pues ésta no
puede crecer también en los glóbulos
rojos del ser humano con la afección que
aprendimos primero aprendimos que los
efectos de una mutación generalmente
pero no siempre aparecerán en el nivel
de la proteína hay algunas excepciones a
esta regla
en segundo lugar aprendimos que las
mutaciones genéticas pueden tener
efectos ventajosos perjudicial
o neutrales según el tipo de mutación el
entorno en el que vive el organismo
afectado así como una multitud de otros
factores